RONALD SMITH: Yeah, so
this is a long list of things
that one might do to reduce
global warming.
But they're all very difficult,
if not impossible.
So are there any points that you
want to make about these?
Any questions about what
I mean by them?
I think we did go
over this last
time, if I'm not mistaken.
There are lots of other
recommendations or suggestions
that have been made under
the general title of
geoengineering.
But one I indicated there is
to install an umbrella-like
object out in space, somewhere
between the earth and the sun,
so that it casts a shadow
on the earth.
And, therefore, reduces the
total amount of sunlight
hitting the earth.
A related suggestion is that
we put a layer of small
particles, kind of like
volcanoes have done naturally
from time to time, put a layer
of small particles in the
stratosphere that will increase
the albedo of the
earth and reflect the Sun's
radiation back into space, and
thereby cool the earth.
The question for something like
that, though, is what
material do we put in there?
They would have to be very fine
particles or they would
just fall out.
If they have some kind of weird
chemistry, like sulfate
particles, what would they do
to the chemistry of the
atmosphere?
So whenever you think of
something, some little clever
idea pops into your mind,
unfortunately there's probably
100 unintended consequences on
these geoengineering ideas.
So they have to be thought
through extremely carefully
before any of them could
be implemented.
While climate research is quite
a mature area now, there
are some areas within it that
require further thought.
For example, we're still missing
a complete theory of
the ice ages.
We think that maybe this
Milankovitch forcing has
played a role.
But that Milankovitch forcing
is very weak actually.
The obliquity change, the tilt
of the earth's axis, is only a
couple of degrees one
way or the other.
The procession theory, which
changes the orientation of the
tilt of the earth's axis,
changes the way the seasons
work, but oppositely in
the two hemispheres.
So if you're looking globally,
that influence cancels right
out completely.
So you have to make up some
argument about why one
hemisphere is more important
than the other.
So we're missing a complete
theory there.
We're also missing a theory
of Venus' climate history.
How it got from being an
earth-like planet to something
that's much, much hotter.
And that's important, as I
mentioned, because there's
some worry that the earth's
atmosphere might follow a
similar path.
Theory of solar variability, now
we know that the sun has
gotten hotter over the
millennia, over
the age of the earth.
And we know that there's a
sunspot cycle, an 11 year and
a 22 year cycle, on the number
of sun spots on the
surface of the Sun.
And we think that that may
have had a very minor
influence on the amount of
radiation reaching the earth.
But that theory is not
well fleshed out.
There are some statistical
relationships
that have been proposed.
But the physical mechanisms for
this make almost no sense.
And so we need to further
understand why the sun might
vary in its strength and
what influence that
would have on the earth.
The theory of positive feedback
I'm going to be
talking more about that
in just a minute--
the idea that there are these
processes on earth that will
tend to amplify climate
change.
The ones that we've talked about
already have been ice
albedo feedback.
Right?
More snow in a colder climate
makes the albedo larger,
reflects more radiation, cools
the earth more, and that might
spiral on itself.
There's the water
vapor feedback.
A warmer climate would put
more water vapor in the
atmosphere certainly.
Water vapor is an important
greenhouse gas that would warm
the climate further and so on.
And then one that's been talked
about more recently,
seems to be going on with the
last 100 years or so, is
carbon dioxide feedback, where
a warmer climate is beginning
to allow carbon trapped in
permafrost to decay and be
added to the atmosphere.
Also ocean water, when you
heat it, it can hold less
carbon dioxide dissolved
in water.
So that CO2 is going
to be added.
So this acts on a slower time
scale perhaps, but there's
some worry that there's a carbon
dioxide feedback that
may be starting to happen.
That one has to do--that last
one has to do with this next
one, how greenhouse
concentrations are controlled.
We don't have a complete
understanding
of the carbon cycle.
Or how some of the other
greenhouse gases, like
methane, ozone, oxides of
nitrogen there's not a
complete understanding of how
they are controlled in the
earth's atmosphere.
The last IPPC report, the one
that you've been looking at,
the AR4, is full of apologies
for how little they can say
about regional climates.
The problem is that these global
climate models roughly
agree in their predictions of
how the global temperature
will change.
But they disagree, to a large
extent, about how the climates
of different continents and
different sub regions within
continents will change.
So this is a big area
of research.
In fact, my group is interested
a little bit in how
global changes will influence
local and regional climates.
We don't understand very well
how clouds would change,
aerosols, how those two things
would impact the earth's
albedo in a different climate.
And this question of whether we
can re-bury carbon dioxide
into the earth is receiving a
lot of funding and a lot of
research at the moment.
Those are some of the
active areas.
If any of you were to get
involved in climate research,
there's a good chance you'd
probably be working on one of
those problems. Although, maybe
I've left off a couple
of newly emerging ideas.
So the last thing I want to
talk about in this set of
lectures is something called
climate sensitivity.
And it's basically an attempt
to simplify and quantify how
earth will respond, how the
earth's climate will respond,
to changes in radiative
forcing.
I'll define radiative forcing
in just a minute.
There are two different common
definitions for climate
sensitivity.
So I need you to be aware
of both of these.
So when you pick up a paper on
climate sensitivity you can
spot which definition
the author is using.
One definition is, how much
would the earth's climate warm
if there was a doubling
of CO2?
That's a commonly used
definition for climate
sensitivity.
The other one is, how much would
the earth warm if you
increased the radiation hitting
the surface of the
earth by one watt per
square meter?
Now these two things can be
related, roughly, because a
CO2 doubling when you add CO2 to
the atmosphere you increase
the absorption and the
re-emission of longwave
radiation.
And a doubling of the CO2 is
approximately adding 3.7 watts
per square meter of radiative
forcing back to the
surface of the earth.
So you trap the outgoing
longwave radiation, you warm
the atmosphere, and then
that readmits back to
earth about that much.
So you can go back and forth
between those two definitions
using that kind of relationship,
that quantity.
Now the reason I like it, the
reason I want to stick it in
here, is that it's being used
more and more as a compact way
to compare different models.
For example, the National
Center for Atmospheric
Research has a global
climate model.
The Department of Energy has
a global climate model.
NASA has a global
climate model.
Several in Europe, the
Russians have one.
How do you compare them?
One way is to use this measure
of their sensitivity.
It's been found in that way
that there are some
significant differences
between these models.
And it's been a help to
find out why these
models are so different.
Also, it's a nice way to
summarize some paleoclimate
data of the type that you and
I have been looking at a
couple of weeks ago.
And I like it because it
illustrates the role of these
climate feedbacks.
So it turns out that these
climate sensitivity values,
almost no matter how you compute
them, are larger than
you would expect if you left
off the feedbacks.
And so by that increase in
sensitivity you can show what
role these climate feedbacks
are having.
So for all these reasons,
we're going to
take a look at this.
Now, so the definitions.
Radiative forcing, extra
radiation at the earth's
surface relative to
preindustrial time.
That's the way radiative forcing
is defined in the
global warming debate.
I wouldn't call that a
universal definition.
But in the global
warming debate
that's how it's defined.
These are the primary feedbacks
we're talking about.
And occasionally you'll find
a discussion of a runaway
climate where the feedbacks, the
positive feedbacks, are so
strong that they would take over
and drive the climate to
an extreme state, like has
happened on Venus.
Unlikely for earth, but it's
part of the conversation.
I've got to define okay, now
there's another variable that
comes in, in how you define
climate sensitivity.
And that has to do with, what
feedbacks do you include in
the calculation?
So I'm going to define something
called the Black
Body sensitivity, which has
no feedbacks in it.
It's based on the
Stefan-Boltzmann law only,
which you remember, from earlier
in the course, is the
fact that the radiation emitted
from an object's
surface goes like the fourth
power of the temperature.
That was the Stefan-Boltzmann
law.
There's something called the
Charney sensitivity.
Charney was a scientist
who chaired the first
investigative panel
on global warming.
And he tried to base their final
report on a particular
definition of climate
sensitivity that included some
short-term feedbacks,
but excluded some of
the longer term ones.
For example, he included water
vapor feedbacks, snow/albedo
feedback, and cloud feedback.
But he excluded any feedback
connected with the oceans, the
ice sheets, or carbon
dioxide changes.
And that's become known, in
the literature, as Charney
sensitivity.
It's probably valid on periods
of time of, say, well 20 to 50
years, something like that.
When you go to longer terms,
however, maybe 100, 200, 300
years, you have to realize that
other slower adjustments
in the climate system are going
to be happening, such as
changes to deep ocean
temperature, changes in the
ice sheets.
Sea level will be rising.
Biomass on the continents
may be changing.
And the carbon dioxide may be
responding to changes in the
ocean and the land surface,
the land biomass.
So that would be called
long-term sensitivity.
Makes you realize this subject
is not dirt simple.
I mean, it's got some complexity
to it, depending on
the time frame that you're
talking about and the
feedbacks that you're allowing
in the calculation.
So here's the easy one, Black
Body sensitivity.
If I've got an object, like a
planet, receiving a certain
amount of radiation from the
sun, you know that it'll
increase its temperature, or
adjust its temperature, so
that it radiates to space
just as much as it's
receiving from the sun.
So it'll adjust it's own
temperature to come into that
kind of radiative equilibrium.
Well then, if I were to increase
the amount received
from the sun by 1 watt per
square meter, how much must
the temperature rise in order
to establish a new
equilibrium?
Pretty simple idea, right?
So there's the Stefan-Boltzmann
law.
I'm going to do a quick little
calculus trick here that some
of you may not be
familiar with.
But if I take the derivative
of F with respect to
temperature, I get 4 times sigma
T to the third times the
change in temperature.
And if I rearrange, bring the
dF under and that down under
here, I get that formula.
The change in temperature for
each change in flux is given
by 1 over 4 sigma
T to the third.
I can plug numbers in.
That Stefan-Boltzmann constant
is a fixed constant.
I can use the temperature of
our planet, of 288 Kelvin,
plug it into that formula.
And I immediately get this
rather interesting number.
For every watt per square meter
that I add to the earth
in the form of radiative energy,
it'll warm by 0.2
degrees Kelvin.
That is the simplest way to
compute climate sensitivity.
That's a pretty small number.
And the reason why, as we will
see the reason why it's fairly
small is we have not
included any of
these positive feedbacks.
Now this is a calculation
you can do for yourself.
Just try putting in different
values of F or T and computing
it and you'll see that that is
the rate at which the two
things are--the slope at which
the two things are related to
each other.
Any questions on that?
So we use this value as kind
of our foundation, right?
Now, if you look at the IPCC
report let me get the lights
down this summarizes the
radiative forcing, using the
definition that I gave
a moment ago.
This is since the beginning of
the industrial revolution.
It shows how much the radiation
reaching the surface
of the earth has changed
and for what reason.
Carbon dioxide is the
biggest reason.
That increase in carbon dioxide,
we've seen, caused
about 1.7 watts per square meter
added greenhouse forcing
at the surface of the earth.
However, methane, N2O, and the
halocarbons have added
something too.
Tropospheric ozone
has added more.
And then on the negative side
and I talked about this a
couple days ago aerosols, mostly
sulfate aerosols from
coal burning, has had
a negative effect.
Well when you add all these
together, these
roughly cancel these.
And you get a value that's
about what CO2 would
have been by itself.
That doesn't mean that CO2
is alone in importance.
The others are important too.
But generally these cancel those
and you get a value of
about 1 and 1/2 meters
per second for
the radiative forcing.
And so if you then just use the
Black Body sensitivity for
that, that would give
you about 0.3
degree Kelvin warming.
And we know, in fact, from our
data, that the warming of our
planet since the industrial
revolution began is about 0.8.
So it's quite a bit larger
than this value.
We can formalize that.
So let's try to compute
radiative forcing based on the
data that we have.
Over the last 100 years we've
had about 0.8 degree warming.
From the last slide, we've got
about 1.5 watts per square
meter radiative forcing.
So if I divide one by the other,
I get a sensitivity
based on the radiation
definition of 0.5 Kelvin.
That then is about 2 and 1/2
times the sensitivity there.
So the sensitivity that we're
seeing in our planet is about
2 and 1/2 times what we compute
from a simple Black
Body forcing law.
This then, is evidence that the
feedbacks are working, the
positive feedbacks
are working.
You could re-formula that as
a warming per CO2 doubling.
And you get about 2 degrees
Kelvin for every CO2 doubling.
I want to do this
one other way.
I know I'm beating this to
death, but you remember this
plot, from the Pleistocene, the
advance and retreat of the
glaciers over the last
400,000 years.
Well, here we have a temperature
signature on the
bottom and a CO2 signature
on the top.
We can convert the
CO2 signature
to a radiative forcing.
And here's how that
argument goes.
So that's a warming of about 5
degrees between glacial and
interglacial times.
We estimate a change in the
longwave forcing of about 7
watts per square meter.
Divide one by the other, I get
about 0.7 degrees Kelvin per
watt per square meter.
Now that's slightly larger than
the one we had on the
last slide from the
last 100 years.
And most people believe that
that number is larger than the
what did we have for that 0.5,
0.7, because you get these
extra long-term feedbacks
coming in.
So there's still a lot of
argument in the literature
about that.
But the general interpretation
is that when you go to this
longer time scale of a couple
hundred thousand years, you
get some longer--some other
positive feedbacks that make
the climate even more sensitive
to radiative forcing.
Any questions on that?
Yeah, so I'll just wrap that up
by saying, as expected, our
climate is about 3 times more
sensitive to radiative forcing
than Black Body would suggest,
due to positive feedbacks like
water vapor feedback and
snow/albedo feedback.
And when you go to longer time
scales, it becomes even
slightly more sensitive due to,
possibly, some other feedbacks.
Yes?
STUDENT: Was the 5K increase
from like the lowest
temperature to the highest
temperature on that graph?
PROFESSOR: On the glacial one?
STUDENT: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I tried to
well, I didn't go to
the very max and the very min,
but I tried to take an average
of the minimum and kind
of a general value
for the higher ones.
I didn't push it to the limit.
You can't read that
scale there.
But that would be slightly
larger than 5 degrees if you
went from minimum to maximum.
So I've reduced it
a little bit.
I didn't want to let
the noise, you
know, drive my answer.
I wanted to use average
values.
Yeah, okay.
So that's the summary.
So this is everything then.
We did all of these subjects.
And today we just finished
up the concept of climate
sensitivity.
Are there any general questions
about global warming?
Okay, if not, we'll
leave it there.
And I want to do one
other thing today.
I think we can get it in.
Yeah, because population is a
driver in global warming, I
wanted to just to spend the rest
of the period I'm not an
expert in demography or
population studies.
But there's a few things that
are quite obvious, that even I
can understand.
And I wanted to lay
those out for you.
Because it's intimately
connected with all these
environmental issues, including
the air pollution
which we'll be studying next
time and on Friday.
So these are the terms you're
going to have to know.
The fertility rate is the number
of children that a
woman would bear in
her lifetime.
The growth rate of a population
would be the rate
of change of the population as
a fraction of the existing
population.
In other words, a
relative rate.
Not a number of people per year,
but like a percent per
year, or something like that.
We'll talk about the special
case of exponential growth,
where the population would
follow a pure exponential
curving rising curve.
I'll talk about population
density, urbanization, the
so-called demographic
transition, and
the population pyramid.
So in the next few minutes, I'll
introduce each of these
terms.
Population versus time, going
back 50,000 years, human
population rose very slowly
over most of the period of
time when humans were evolving,
because, well, life
is difficult.
The death rate was high due to
disease, due to accidents, due
to all kinds of things.
And it isn't really until you
got in the very recent period
of time where you began to get
this rapid, very rapid,
increase in human population.
Probably the biggest change in
the rate of growth had to do
with the changes in medicine, I
would say the germ theory of
disease and inoculations.
Both of which are
rather recent.
We're talking about the 19th,
in some cases the early part
of the 20th century.
1920, 1930, 1940 when mass
inoculations began to be used.
Anyway it's a very curious
curve, so slow and so flat for
so long, and then rising so
rapidly now just in the last
100 years or so.
That is partly controlled
by the fertility rate.
And here's a diagram from
Wiki about that.
What you have for each country
and this is by country is a
fertility rate from
0--or from 1 to 7.
So the United States
would have a value
somewhere around 2.
Remember this is the number of
births per woman in her life.
And a lot of other countries
have that medium gray color,
which puts you around 2.
The Soviet Union, especially
Ukraine, is even less than
that, however.
And most of Africa and the
Middle East are dramatically
higher, generally in
the range 4, 5, 6.
That doesn't necessarily mean
that their population is
increasing rapidly, although
that's true also.
But the fertility rate is one of
the components that goes in
to determining the rate
of population growth.
Everybody understand this
definition of fertility rate?
It's controlled by a number
of factors, but a
lot of it is cultural.
A lot of it has to do with
expectations, having children
to take care of you in your
old age, to help with the
farm, or because you don't
have a way to control
population.
A number of--a wide variety
of things come into
the fertility rate.
The role of women in society
is a big one as well.
Here's the fertility rate
plotted versus GDP, the Gross
Domestic Product, that makes
it pretty clear there's a
relationship between how much
money people have, their
standard of living, and
the fertility rate.
USA is here.
Generally, for the developed
world the fertility
rate is 2 or less.
Whereas for the underdeveloped
world the fertility rate can
be very much higher.
And this magic value here, of
2.3, is the replacement rate.
You have to have a fertility
rate of about 2.3 in order to
maintain a steady population.
There are a few outliers that
have to do with the special
cultural conditions of
those countries.
Stop me if there are
questions on this.
So let's look at the fertility
rate for the United States and
Canada since 1940.
There was a big bulge in
fertility rate, reaching 3.7
for the USA around 1955.
And that is really what's
responsible for what's called
the Baby Boom in the
United States.
And I guess you are the children
of the Baby Boom
generation or something
approximate to that.
And then immediately after that
came a movement called
ZPG, Zero Population Growth.
Maybe that movement caused this
drop, or maybe it was
just changes in background
cultural or economic
conditions.
But there was a dramatic drop
in the fertility rate in the
United States from 3.7
down to less than 2.
And now it's come up a little
bit for the United States to
just about the replacement
rate.
Canada is roughly similar.
The details may be a little
different, they haven't jumped
up at the end.
But they followed roughly
the same curve.
Any questions on that?
So this is a wild
swing, right?
This is a huge variation in
just a few years in one
particular country.
Europe is famous for having
a low fertility rate.
And here are some
of the numbers.
Remember the replacement
rate is about 2.3.
Italy has 1.3.
And some of the Eastern European
countries are even
lower than that.
France is higher.
They've tried to keep their
population, their
fertility rate up.
But they don't have it quite
at replacement levels.
And Spain is down
at 1.3 as well.
So Europe, as a whole, generally
has a very low
fertility rate.
We saw that in the earlier map
as well, here, as opposed to
some other developing
parts of the world.
And China has gone through
wild swings, as
has the United States.
For somewhat different reasons,
perhaps, but the
curve is somewhat similar.
It climbed even higher than the
United States, much higher
in fact, up to 6.5.
And that, I think, was part of
the cultural revolution where
it was every woman's duty to
have as many children as she
possibly could for the strength
of the state.
And then talk about a complete
turnabout they've now dropped
down to less than 2.
And, of course, that is largely
due to China's one
child policy, kind of flipping
the political pressure on
families and individuals.
So wild swings in
fertility rate.
Now we'll move to this
fractional growth rate then.
So, of course, this is now a
combination of birth rate and
mortality rate.
How many children are
born every year?
How many people die
every year?
You have to know both of those
to then get the total
fractional growth rate
of the population.
And there again, these colors
follow the same trend.
As the Soviet Union has the
lowest growth rate, well 1--
well below 0.
They're losing population.
And all the other countries are
gaining population, but at
a rate ranging from 3% per year
to just a small fraction
of a percent per year.
So that's the total fractional
growth rate.
Here is the way you would
compute that.
Here are some numbers.
For example, China population
in 2010 and 1990.
Well that's a 20 year span, so
you can get an approximation
by just taking the percent
change over that period of
time and dividing that by
the number of years.
So divide that by 20 and you
get a value that's just
slightly less than
1% per year.
And that would be that percent,
or that fractional
growth rate for population
in China.
That's how you do
the calculation.
In some cases taking a 20 year
estimate might be blurring
some details.
If the growth has been changing
rapidly over time,
what you would be getting here
is some kind of average over a
fluctuating quantity.
But nevertheless, you see how
easy it is to do that
calculation, if you don't mind
losing some of the details,
some of the rapid
changes in time.
So globally then, this is what
the fractional growth rate has
been doing and is
projected to do.
But these projections
are quite uncertain.
I wouldn't pay too much
attention to the blue curve.
Globally we've had, over the
last couple of decades, we've
had growth rates--
this is not fertility rate,
this is growth rate--
of about 2% per year, which is
quite a large growth rate.
It has been decreasing.
At the present time, it's
more like 1% per year.
But that's still quite
a large growth rate.
And then it's predicted
that will continue to
drop as we go forward.
But that will depend a lot upon
the future economy, the
future cultural development of
the countries that have the
highest populations.
Now this concept of exponential
growth, you've
probably heard it.
If the fractional growth rate is
constant, that is, if this
quantity were constant in time,
over some period of
time, then the population
will grow exponentially.
Now what does that mean, to
say the population grows
exponentially?
The exponential function defines
a system whose annual
increase is proportional to
the population itself.
In other words, its rate of
increase is proportional to
the population that it has.
That is what is meant by an
exponential increase.
Sometimes that word
is misused.
Sometimes in the popular
literature someone will be
saying, well, you know I'm rich,
my bank account amount
is growing exponentially.
And by that he might
just mean rapidly.
But that's not what exponential
really means.
Exponential means it's growing
at a rate proportional to how
much you have.
Now, if you're getting a fixed
interest rate in your account,
then it would be exponential.
It'll grow at a rate that will
increase as you get more and
more money in the bank.
So that might be an accurate
representation.
Remember, exponential doesn't
refer to some rate of
increase, it relates to the
relationship between the rate
of increase and the amount of
the standing population that
you have at any particular
moment.
So in other words, births
minus deaths, really,
proportional to population.
So we write it this way.
Population, as a function
of time, is given by the
population at some reference
time, call it 0, and then P to
the plus alpha t, where alpha
is the growth rate and t is
the time that's elapsed
since your
reference time has occurred.
So if the growth rate, for
example, is 1% per year--
and that was a number
that we have about
now for planet earth--
and if that were to
remain constant.
in other words, if this curve
was level at 1% per year, then
here's how you could
do the calculation.
After 100 years, putting in 100
years into there and 0.01
year to the minus 1 in for
alpha, the units will cancel.
And in this case, the product is
equal to 1, in this special
simple example.
So it's going to be exp to the
1, which has a value-- you can
check it on your calculator--
of 2.7.
So a growth rate of 0.01 over
100 years would give a growth
rate factor of 2.7.
So however many people you had
at the beginning of the 100
year period, put that there,
multiply it times 2.7, and
you'll get--
it's roughly a tripling, roughly
a tripling of the
population over 100 years if you
have a growth rate of 1%
percent per year.
Remember it's compound interest.
The rate increases
as the population increases.
Questions on that?
Now this is a bit of a fiction,
because, as you've
just seen, population
growth rates change
quite a bit over time.
And so, while you can do rough
calculations with this, a real
population demographer would
probably never use this.
He would go step by step and
calculate it assuming a
variable growth rate rather than
assuming a constant one.
So here are the current
UN population
projections for our planet.
Data up to this point, and then
uncertain projections,
depending on what you think
the growth rate will
be around the world.
So we crossed 6 billion back
in 2000, roughly 2000.
We crossed 7 billion just,
what was that, 3
weeks ago, I think.
And in the future, well
the projections vary
all over the place.
But by, let's say, 2080, this
looks like 2080, some
calculations would have
us at 12 billion.
Some would have us at 9.
And some would have us
declining, population already
getting back towards
6 billion.
So great uncertainties
in this.
But still great potential for
environmental difficulties, if
either of those curves
are realized.
Another issue that comes up
is population density.
How many people per square
kilometer do you have?
And this is a map of
population density.
Units are people per
square kilometer.
And there are some countries--
and this is by country so this
can be quite misleading,
because for a given country they
put a uniform color over
the whole country.
So it's the total population
divided by the total area of
the country, then painted
as a uniform color
over the whole country.
That's quite unrealistic.
But it will give us a place
to start to talk
about population density.
India, as a country, has a
population exceeding 1,000
people per square kilometer,
which is enormous.
Whereas something like Australia
is in the lightest
shade that they have,
less than 10
people per square kilometer.
Wide variation in
that quantity.
But again, this is quite
misleading because it's done
by country.
United States, this is
per square mile.
Remember, the United States
unfortunately is still on an
old English system of measure.
So very often you'll find
population per square mile
instead of per square
kilometer.
You can do the conversion easily
to go back and forth.
But once again, doing it by
state is misleading, because
there are parts of California
that are
nearly empty of people.
And there are very densely
populated areas of
California and so on.
But even averaging over states,
you'll find a big
difference between Montana, for
example, and New Jersey
and Rhode Island.
Now, if you want to read
about the role
of population density--
not all demographers would put a
great emphasis on population
density, but Jared Diamond,
in this book, Collapse--
how many have read that book?
I thought a few of you would
have. He, in places in that
book, makes a pretty strong
case for the importance of
population density.
He really thinks it matters that
populations have enough
space to live.
And I partly agree with that.
But he maybe takes it--
some examples he gives wouldn't
carry over to other
civilizations that he didn't
talk about in his book.
But anyway, he makes a strong
case for the importance of
population density.
And I party believe that too.
So I encourage you to take a
look at that book if you get a
chance, because it makes the
case very nicely for the
importance of population
density.
When you think about what the
limiting resources are for
living on our planet, water,
food, energy, living space,
even these other ones, like
water and food and energy, to
some extent they all depend on
having enough area as well.
For example, energy from
hydroelectric requires a large
catchment area of rain in order
to get hydroelectric.
Farmland, obviously food from
farms requires lots of area.
So just scanning this list and
realizing that many of those
have a relationship to
population density would, I
think, partly confirm Jared
Diamond's idea that living
space is an important part of
the success of a culture.
Okay, now to correct the
misimpression from those
earlier country-based and
state-based population
densities.
People don't live uniformly
distributed over a
country or a state.
In fact, a higher and higher
fraction of populations are
moving to cities.
They're abandoning the land
and moving to cities.
So this is a plot, on the x-axis
1950 into the future,
2050, the percent of the
population that's living in
urban versus rural areas.
Back in the 1950's, 70%
was rural, 30% urban.
And we've crossed that boundary,
we've crossed that
crossover point.
And in the future, we'll have
more people living clustered
together in cities.
That doesn't mean they don't
need the land around the
cities to grow the food and
provide the energy and so on.
But at least their living
density is much larger than
those country-averaged or those
state-averaged values
that I gave you.
And these are some of the
growing megacities, where now
more than half the people in
the world are concentrated
into these large cities.
Yes?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: I don't know.
When you do calculations--
I saw an article recently about
how much energy people
used that live in New York city
versus the rest of New
York state.
And the people who live in New
York city use less energy per
capita then the people that
live in upstate New York.
Probably because of the dense
way that they live and the way
that transportation is so much
easier when you live close.
So I think it could be argued
that this might be a more
efficient way to live.
But that's only one measure.
And I haven't studied the issue
in it's full breadth.
So that would be worth
looking into.
To see whether this might
actually be an advantage for
the environment, to have people
clustered in cities.
Other comments on that?
We need to wrap up.
I do need to give you this.
So there's something called the
demographic transition.
And it goes basically from a
third world country converting
to a first world country.
What happens to its
population?
In the beginning, you've got a
high birth rate, a high death
rate, and a small population.
Standard of living begins to
increase, health is improved.
The first thing that happens
is the death rate drops.
The birth rate stays high.
Because the death rate has
dropped and the birth rate
stays high, population
begins to increase.
Then, at some point culturally,
the birth rate
drops as well.
You end up with a lower birth
rate and a lower death rate
and a larger total population.
We've seen this happen in
country after country.
And if you look at that map
of the world, clearly some
countries in the west,
like the US and
Europe are in this state.
And a lot of the third
world countries are
still in this state.
And a few are in the middle,
doing the demographic
transition.
So this is an important concept
of how you go from one
type of population situation
to the other.
And the other one I want
to leave you with--
I'm out of time-- but you
have to know about
the population pyramid.
So a country that has a stable
population, here's a plot of
how many people you have,
male and female, in
different age groups.
A country that has a stable
population usually has a
population pyramid like this.
A country that has a rapidly
growing population has a
pyramid like this, a lot
of young people.
And as they get older, of
course, the overall population
will increase very rapidly.
Well, you can see this
immediately, because if you
drive into a small town in the
Middle East or in Africa, the
number of children that come
running out of the house to
see who's visiting their village
tells you you've got a
population curve like that.
And that will do it.
00:47:52,600 --> 00:00:00,000
Okay, we're finished.